what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today's video is very very
interesting because it can potentially
change things for Marvel Studios moving
forward and maybe not just Marvel
Studios but other studios in general
definitely Star Wars because Star Wars
is owned by Disney just like Marvel
Studios but this also could Ripple over
into Warner Brothers Discovery because
of course they produce DC content now as
you probably read because I'll probably
put it in the title Marvel Studios is
looking to seek action against some
leaks over Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania they have already sought and are
currently seeking legal action against a
Reddit page and the reason that they are
doing this is because essentially the
entire script for Ant-Man and the WASP
fundamania got leaked and was posted to
reddit online it wasn't the actual
script but it was literally every single
line of dialogue from the movie so
essentially the the entire movie was
leaked online although it wasn't visual
it was on paper but it was still
nonetheless the entire dialogue was
leaked online now I did not cover it on
my channel for this specific reason
there is actually a very big difference
from rumors and things that insiders
have posted on their Twitter accounts or
patreon accounts telling us little leaks
here and there about things that they've
heard from people in the studio there's
a very big difference between those
things and actual property of Marvel
Studios or any other Studios out there
this includes photos videos definitely
scripts or anything else that could get
out that is actually their property that
they do not want out now we are going to
go over all of the details about what
Marvel Studios is doing seeking legal
action against the subreddit group but
again I do also want to talk about how
this could potentially change things for
Marvel Studios moving forward they might
not have as many leaks going out as they
used to now I myself and a lot of people
that I know used to cover a lot of leaks
on the channel and we still do we talk
about rumors we talk about things
insiders say but when it comes to script
leaks and when it comes to actual leaked
footage we don't do that anymore
specifically because we knew that once
we got on Disney's radar it would be
hard to get off and legal action could
be taken against us which is why we have
stopped over the years but don't worry
we'll always continue to report on the
juicy rumors and things that insiders
have to say that is still fair game but
let's take a look at what Marvel Studios
and Disney are doing as far as legal
action is concerned against this
subreddit group now it's against the
subreddit group Marvel Studios spoilers
and as of today the page has been shut
down so Marvel Studios is really
cracking down on all of these leaks and
here's what they did per a report from
variety Disney filed a request on Friday
March 10th on behalf of Marvel and a
federal district court in California
they asked the court to issue a subpoena
that would mandate Reddit to identify
the users who were involved in a
dialogue week about story details about
Ant-Man 3 on the Marvel Studios spoilers
subreddit page around January 20th of
2023. specifically cited parties are the
MSS mods as well as that of any other
users responsible for posting editing
and or maintaining the content on the
subreddit from January 15th to February
15th the request is in pursuant of the
US Digital Millennium Copyright Act dmca
and like I mentioned as of right now
that subreddit has been shut down Reddit
itself has issued a statement stating
Reddit is committed to protecting our
users as privacy we have rigorous
processes in place to access legal
requests an object when appropriate so
that's kind of vague it seems like
Reddit is protecting the privacy of
these people who posted because Reddit
is supposed to be an anonymous Forum
unless you happen to put your name in a
username but that's still a pretty vague
response we're unsure right now if
Reddit is is actually going to hand over
the identities of those users who were
on that subreddit page now something
else that is pretty interesting right
now is that the whole entire reddit
website or app or just Forum in general
doesn't really seem to be working at
this time it's very very glitchy you can
go to the site you can go to the app but
you can't really access any of the
subreddit Pages this is no doubt due to
what is happening with Marvel Studios
and that subreddit page so Reddit in
general could kind of be in trouble here
now they're most likely just doing this
as a precaution because the vast
majority of Reddit is not leaks there is
a lot that can be found on Reddit
however where it kinda gets complicated
in this case is the content was first
removed after receiving a dmca takedown
request from Marvel and it gets a little
more complicated when you consider the
fact that the Reddit thread is embedded
content that is hosted by Google meaning
Google could take you right to that page
right to where that leak was if you
typed in Ant-Man 3 script leak Ant-Man 3
dialogue leak it would take you right to
that Reddit page and although it was
removed thanks to the dmca takedown
request the post was still there this is
kind of where the issue comes in for
Marvel Studios even though the entire
dialogue wasn't still there you could
still read all of the comments on the
thread and many of the comments on the
thread were talking about what the
dialogue said and a lot of what they
were talking about was of course the big
spoilers of the movie now as a report
from torrent freak points out a limited
liability company named mvl film Finance
LLC has requested the United States
district court for a Northern District
of California subpoena both Google and
Reddit for information regarding those
who have used a specific Reddit account
according to court documents the
accounting question like I mentioned is
MSS mods and according to tour and Frank
that has been shared between all of the
moderators for the page now this could
be why the entire website could be
having a big problem right now but the
main point of this is that Marvel
Studios in Disney is not playing around
what's interesting is that the movie has
already been out for a few weeks now now
here's what I think is actually
happening and this is my personal
opinion I'm not really sure if Marvel
Studios can really get anything from
this if they try to sue Reddit or the
subreddit page or the moderators for
that subreddit page there's a couple
things that come with that one is that
if they are indeed suing the actual
moderators for that the redditors
themselves they're probably not going to
get much money because they probably
don't have much money but two they're
going to have to prove that this
actually costs the movie money that it
was actually detrimental to the movie
now we know that Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is not really doing good at
the box office it broke a record for the
most decline in sales between the first
week and the second week but you really
can't link that to a dialogue leak on a
Reddit page I don't personally know how
people saw this leak I don't really know
if a lot of people shared it or not but
I think it would be really hard to seek
damages however I don't really think
that's the point I think the point for
Marvel Studios here is they don't want
their leaks getting out and remember I'm
talking about true leaks like property
that they own scripts videos photos
things that you can actually take legal
action on such as what they are doing
right now this does not include rumors
and things that some leakers say online
so things like oh I heard this actor
could be in this movie or I heard this
character is going to be a major part of
this movie that's different but I do
think that this will kind of change
things going forward I do think that
some leakers out there are going to be a
lot more careful with exactly what they
say and how they say it I do think that
no matter what moving forward we
probably aren't going to see any script
leaks any pics any videos basically
anything that anybody could get sued for
by Marvel Studios and Disney I don't
think we're gonna see that anymore if
you go back to the leaks from Spider-Man
no way home there were legitimate
pictures that were leaked and I didn't
show them I simply talked about them but
I didn't show them for that specific
purpose it was property owned by Sony
that that they could sue for now back
then a lot of people talked about the
picture but didn't actually show it I
think this is going to be even more of
the case now I don't think anybody's
going to be posting any leaked photos
not when a studio could sue you over
them but this actually comes as good
news to a lot of people however at the
same time I do know that there are a lot
of people who enjoy leaks so go ahead
and let us know what you think about
this in the comments down below and are
you one of those people who like to
avoid spoilers or are you a person who
enjoys to see the leaks before the
movies come out because they make you
even more excited I'm somewhere in
between I of course do like to know the
leaks but I don't need to know that Iron
Man dies in Avengers end game before I
see it but let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest MCU
news and yes that will continue to
include rumors and the things that
insiders say online the channel is not
changing at all because we never really
touched the stuff that Marvel Studios
owned anyways so don't forget to
subscribe and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching we'll wolf